let's bring it now michael whoa look at
al albino
outside there got flowers there looks
good the whole thing
yeah dan we we also have occasionally
some hawks and crows
that come by so i've had to hire because
i don't want anybody to interrupt us
oh i have my own security i have a
security force here
i have three of these guys right so
the plastic owls let your running in
snow
if you have crows and hawks in your
backyard go to a gas station
get some ceramic plastic owls for about
a dollar twenty a piece
and that will do the job and you know
what so we're good we're good to go you
know what we call those
owl michaels oh there you go now very
very good thank you very very good the
comedy stylings of dan
you you you have you haven't lost an
instrument um
what was the [ __ ] by the way welcome
to welcome to peacock well thank you
thank you cool uh what was the first nba
game
that you called do you remember
the first nba game i did it for two
years back in the 0304 season christmas
day
03 uh houston at the lakers it was yao
ming
as a rookie it was the kobe shack
gary payton carl maloney with the the
lakers with phil jackson threatening to
retire which he subsequently did and
then came back
so that was the first game i did i did
it with doc rivers
i was looking for a partner they wanted
me to do the nba the funny thing is
i wanted to get some practice games in
that year and
so mark jackson had retired and was
living in santa monica
and we went down to staples and we did
the game and mark was good i remember
mike pearl was
the executive producer of of the nba
and mike said what'd you think and i
said you know mark's going to be really
good someday but he's
green he hadn't done it before i hadn't
done basketball in like 25 years
so i really needed somebody who had some
experience and then my good fortune was
that doc rivers got fired by orlando
that year i think they started one and
ten
and then he and i danced the dance that
year and then he went to boston
and i did one more year of the nba with
ub brown the great newbie browners who's
still going strong
that was number one when you're calling
a game in person without
the audience i think how i i don't know
if you've done that
but like a small crowd like how much
does it help in
in you doing your job well i do have
some experience because when i did the
san francisco giants
in the mid 70s 74 5 and six terrible
team
horrible ballpark uh cold
uh on an august night i remember in
maybe 75
playing san diego each team is 22 games
out of first place
nobody's there it's cold it's terrible
bitter
and they handed me a sheet with the
attendance figure
and i looked at it and i said here's
tonight's attendance
let me just tell you mr mrs jim mcalpine
have come in from mill valley harvey
paluccian has driven up from milpitas
the uh the the bernstein family came up
on a station wagon with the dog but they
left the windows open in the parking lot
and that's what you do and it it was
it's so much more fun obviously when
you're doing it
with a big crowd and great crowd noise
so
this is going to be interesting and
we're going to start you know in kansas
city they're supposed to have
maybe the quarter a quarter of the
stadium so that's two weeks from
thursday
we'll see i don't know what that's gonna
sound like everybody's supposed to wear
a mask
and then uh three weeks from last night
we're right back here we open up this 5
billion dollar stadium in englewood
which is tremendous
it's unbelievable with no fans cowboys
rams on
sunday night football so um it's a lot
of trial and error dana we'll see how it
works out
is there plan b if you can't go
and you and chris have to call it uh by
remote
i've not heard of that i think that
would be extremely difficult and i would
not like that
at all i think
basketball is is in a relatively
confined area so i think you you can you
can call basketball
more easily than you can the other
sports baseball
fairly similar in that regard uh mike
emerick of course is the greatest i mean
mike doing hockey whether he's in the
arena or sitting in his home in detroit
i mean i'm watching him the other night
thinking
he's not missing very much he's missing
maybe two percent and
that two percent is because he's not
he's not there and you've got pierre
mcguire who's there so
that's working out well i think football
is very tough because you have to see
the field you have to see
how they align it's all spread out and
on a 40-yard pass down field
that's going to be a very difficult
thing to call and plus you you just
don't you can't feel it
there's a rhythm to the game uh even
though there's no crowd
you know maybe you'll put in some crowd
noise which i i think is working fairly
well with these other sports
so um i would much much much prefer
to be there and hopefully we don't have
a plan b and and we don't have to do a
game off a monitor
do broadcasters need the pre-season we
know the players
uh do to a certain degree i don't
think so except in this particular
circumstance
uh this is to paraphrase
our great buddy jim nance i mean this a
tradition like
none other this this is a season like
none other so we have to go through
a lot of the protocols that the players
do that other people who are going to be
in the stadium so there are a lot of
things to think about
before we get on the air and that's the
only thing i'm concerned about because
for the most part normally our first
game that we would do would be the hall
of fame game in
candle ohio almost every year that i've
done the nfl
that's how we start and you get into a
rhythm fairly quickly
so you don't need pre-season in that
regard but in this particular case
i think it would have been helpful to
just see hey how do we get into the
stadium what do we do how do we travel
what what what happens
around the game itself i think once we
get on the air it'll be fine
talking al michaels of course the
play-by-play voice nbc sunday night
football i can't believe
that we're a couple of weeks away from
the start of this nfl season
and then you had this false positive
outbreak with the nfl with the testing
alf this is
two weeks from now i mean this could
shut down a game i'm guessing or
i don't know what kind of damage it
would do to the game
well i see that the lab said there was
some contamination
i mean this is not likely to be
necessarily a one-off
we've already had false positives we
know what happened with with matthew
stafford so
this is a day-to-day thing i mean right
now
the league is on schedule to start two
weeks from thursday a lot can happen
between now and then a lot can happen
on that thursday morning who knows you
know what if
patrick mahomes test comes in uh
positive but it was a false positive
we don't know i don't know what's going
to happen here but you know what we're
all
there's so much as you know over the
last six months contradictory
information
don't forget when this thing started oh
it's a winter thing and everybody's sick
right now and
we'll get to summer everybody be fine it
only affects old people not young people
that turned out to be 100 false so
we don't know and everybody says believe
the science well well that lab in new
jersey is part of the science right
so at this point this is an ongoing
saga hopefully it has
a smooth road to to travel
and we get to the end of the season i
think you know right now i think the
season looks like it's going to start on
time
we're ready to go everybody everything
seems to be fine but it's a long way
between now and february
we see these second year quarterbacks
make a jump
uh we've seen this in recent history
where
you know then they become legitimate mvp
candidates you know
mahomes is the latest in lamar jackson
to be able to do this
but when you see these quarterbacks like
what is the one thing that would stand
out that you saw the jump
if you want to you know lamar jackson
from one year to the next uh
patrick mahomes maybe kyler murray this
year you know optically what what is it
that you see where you go that's
different than the year before
and then go all the way back to uh to
russell wilson
they can run and they can throw i mean
they can do both things
so is the day of the drop back in the
pocket quarterback tom brady over
no i mean tom's still pretty good and of
course that's going to be one of the
great stories this year to follow
uh what happens with him but uh
it's it's i don't want to say the new
breed because i was you know reading the
other day about you know
lamar jackson and patrick mahomes have
changed the game
go back to randall cunningham he changed
the game too
and i think sports illustrated had a
story
on the cover in 1988 and called him the
ultimate weapon so you go back to a guy
like cunningham
who did a lot of these same things so
we've had these quarterbacks
through the years who came in and were
able to do both things and now you've
got i mean you know with mahomes and
jackson i mean
i don't want to say taking it to a new
level but these guys are
i mean they're not only great but
they're also exciting and i think this
makes the game better and people want to
see them
uh not only are those guys good but
they're exciting you don't know what's
going to happen
and um and that's what you look for but
you need
special talent to be able to do that but
we're embracing that style now al
whereas before it felt like these
coaches and gm's fought that style
for sure dan and and why wouldn't you i
mean
look at the problems you present for the
defense i mean
if you're defending mahomes or lamar
jackson or somebody like that
you're looking at it from a defensive
coordinator's standpoint a lot
differently than going up against tom
brady
for sure because tom brady's not going
to do the things those other guys do
but so it gives you i don't want to say
more of a headache as a defensive
coordinator because they figured out
ways to do it
but it's something else to think about i
mean within the homes
and we proved it last year the play is
never over
the play is never over and but you know
then again you've got other pocket
quarterbacks like you know
ben roethlisberger coming off an injury
but you know ben
a few years ago uh i once likened him to
trying to tackle an apartment building
he may have gone into the pocket and
everybody's around them and they're at
his feet and you know
trying to knock him down and somehow he
escapes so you know these guys come in
in different styles different models and
it makes the game even more fun to me
you sneak in a gambling reference
occasionally
right yeah sure i have you
bet on games i have not
and i'll tell you why no no i you know i
love to go to uh las vegas i mean i love
to play craps that's the greatest game
ever invented
but i don't bet on sports and dan you've
been around it so long
it's so funny we know so much i mean
chris and i
and fred godelli and drew essikoff and
michelle tafoya
and our core group you know we meet with
the players and the coaches and we know
the owners and the general managers and
the personnel people and
you know nobody studies more tape than
chris we don't know who's going to win
the game
we'll drive out to the game and go what
do you think you know and
50 50 of the time we're wrong so the
great thing to me about sports the most
the wonderful thing is everybody thinks
they know but they don't know
you don't know and that's why i love
sports and that's why i don't bet on
sports
i bet uh when i was younger and
i thought i knew it all and i realized i
didn't enjoy gambling
i didn't watch the game i couldn't i
just it was driving me crazy
and then even if i won i still didn't
enjoy it
and then i went cold turkey i i lost the
orange bowl i lost 3 300
um on an orange ball a lot of money in
those years yes
it was it was a lot of money and i was
up six grand
and uh i i lost three grand and then the
vig
and then i quit i walked away bought my
mom a dishwasher
and uh paid off some school loans but
that i
i have never and you know people always
say hey do you want to put down a dime
on this or
and i go nick no no i don't want to do
that at all
but people always come up and they'll
say the following who do you like
and i go no no i had pete rose
ask me and bob costas at the 1986
playoffs between the mets and the astros
pete comes up to us on the field he goes
who do you like and i said and i've i
don't know that pete's gambling i'm
going well
hey you know you got mike scott and the
the mets can't handle mike scott
and he walks away and bob goes why did
you tell him that i go
i don't know he goes he's going to
gamble you're going to bet on that i'm
going oh my god
nobody nobody knows you know i mean to
me
there are so many examples of you think
you know look there are
so many statistics and analyses out
there right now
and somebody will say to me well you
know what about
the fact that you know on any given
thursday this
i'm going to stop it and and and it's so
true because
especially in all the years i did the
triple crown
and i think i did 15 derbies in a row
between 1986 and 2000
with a great jim mckay and and others
like hank goldberg
and people would come up to me at
churchill downs walking through the
grandstand
who do you like and i would go
seabiscuit
or i would go man a war and they would
look down at the program
well where is he what race is that
nobody knows but this is this is why
sports is are so great
when's the last time you went to a game
doing a game
and you were absolutely wrong
in what you thought was going to play
out
or the other way that you were
absolutely positively
correct that this was going to happen no
never i mean there were i'd have to
think back you know to
like last year you know there are sunday
night games that just
turned out to be the exact opposite of
the way you think they will
will play out and we've had a few of
them uh last year i mean
one game we didn't do the game but we
did the game the following week when
minnesota played the 49ers in the
playoffs and minnesota shocked new
orleans
you know you think the vikings don't
have any chance to go into the dome
and beat the saints in that particular
game and then the next week
you kind of you know as we're doing
minnesota at san francisco now you're
thinking about
well they beat new orleans and now they
do they have a chance to meet san
francisco
and in analyzing that game we just felt
that they
they'd uh they'd used all of their
energy and
whatever it was that enabled them to
beat new orleans and of course san
francisco
knocked them off relatively handily but
um it's
you know look the other thing too is i'm
watching
you guys were talking about it before
i'm watching that game yesterday
and somebody said to me well you know
what do you think of the way that uh
they're doing the nba and the nhl and i
said it's pretty good i'm getting used
to it
but that game yesterday that clipper
dallas game
was so compelling in so many ways and of
course the dramatic and fantastic ending
to that
game uh i thought you forgot about all
of the rest of it you forgot it's in the
gym you've forgotten to said
the fake fans it's the dog the animated
dog and this and all that stuff
you forgot about all of that and uh it
just became a great basketball game and
that was a terrific
you know doc rivers is a great pal of
mine and uh you know i like to do to
tech stock after the game and normally
congratulate them
i didn't know what to say you know this
is like it's you know not quite a
death of a relative but i mean that was
a that was a bad one
and i uh i just wrote to him last night
i said look
in my mind now the mavericks are out of
miracles that's it
you'll get you'll get them on tuesday
and you're the king of miracles
well i know i know about one anyway yeah
uh well hopefully uh we pull off another
one we have an nfl season here in a
couple of weeks
and uh it's great to talk to you hope uh
everything's good i know you got a
busy day probably what what are you
doing today
i'm taking these guys out for a walk
[Laughter]
now today we've got a couple of zoom
calls we're getting ready for the season
and we're talking about what we're gonna
do and
you know we got two games that first
week we've got the houston at
kansas city come back here for dallas at
the rams so uh
i'm immersed in it my man studying for
the final exam i love it
i love it welcome again this is great
have a great
long run with you and the and the
danettes
guys doing okay yeah yeah everybody now
everybody's uh being smart for the most
part i think yeah
we're we're trying to be non-essential
now
stay that way thank you we're good at
that
the great al michaels play by play boys
sunday night football
we're we're two weeks away from football
crazy